the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lesson today hopefully we'll
serve two purposes on the one hand we
will give a nice application of the
chain rule now that we've had two units
devoted to working with the chain rule I
thought you might enjoy seeing how it's
used in places which aren't quite that
obvious that places that we wouldn't
expect it to be used at least and
secondly I would like to pick as my
application one which comes up in many
many different contexts and without
further ado the topic I want to cover
today is called integrals involving
parameters now that sounds like a big
mouthful let me motivate that for you
Utley first of all physically and then
in terms of a couple of geometric
examples you all know from past
experience my great ability with
physical applications so I won't even
try to find anything profound here let
me just take a pseudo example pointing
out what type of situation we're trying
to deal with and leaving it to your own
backgrounds to see places where the same
principle could have been applied but
hopefully in a more practical meaningful
way to you imagine for example that we
have a platform that we're looking along
in the X direction and we've punched
holes in this platform say and liquid is
trickling through these various holes
the holes are all on a horizontal line
this way we what we're going to do is
we're going to focus our attention on a
particular particle of the liquid and
we're going to watch it as it falls and
what we would like to do is find how far
that particle fell say during the first
second of its flight
well obviously from a calculus point of
view the first thing we have to do is
know what the velocity function is
because ultimately we would like to
integrate the velocity now notice that
we would expect the velocity to be
depending on time if this were a freely
falling situation we'd expect the usual
gravitational type situation or whatever
the situation happened to be we would
expect on the one hand that the velocity
does depend on the time on the other
hand because of how the streams are
flowing we don't know what's happening
above here that's causing the water
- shootout we don't know what the
initial velocity is coming out of each
of these holes and in the sense that a
different opening may give rise to a
different velocity of stream coming out
all I'm trying to bring out here is that
as we try to focus our attention on a
particular opening we find that the
velocity of the particle that we're
following during that for a second is a
function both of its position X in other
words X sub 0 in this case because we're
focusing in at x equals x0 and the time
T as T goes from 0 to 1 and we then
simply integrate along the vertical
direction here we find Y as a function
of X 0 from 0 to 1 V of X 0 T DT in
other words the distance once we're
through integrating you see notice that
the integration is with respect to T so
when we're through integrating this
being a definite integral T no longer
appears we have a function of X 0 alone
saying nothing more than the distance
that the particle falls during the first
second is a function of the position of
the opening along the line here now at
any rate the practical application is
not so much writing down this equation
as the inverse is the case namely in
many practical applications we are given
this particular integral and for some
reason or other want to determine what V
itself is in other words we often want
to find the derivative given the
integral alright let's just let it go at
that for the time being the important
point is I want you to see an example of
an integral let me just write this here
in more abstract form it's it appears to
be a definite integral a to be the
function inside the integrand is
apparently a function of two variables x
and y say in this case X 0 and T one of
the variables is a variable of
integration in this case Y and the other
variable is being treated as a constant
and that's where the word parameter
comes in X is a parameter meaning a
variable constant in the sense that for
this particular problem X is chosen to
be in some
and remains fixed in other words this is
some function of X when we're all
through here all right as a geometric
example imagine the following situation
we have a surface W equals f of X Y we
take the plane x equals x 0 and
intersect this surface with that
particular plane we get a curve you see
now we look at that curve corresponding
to two points P and Q where P and Q are
determined by the Y values a and B in
other words P corresponds to y equals a
Q corresponds to y equals B and now a
very natural question that might come up
is that we would like to find the area
of this particular plane region there
was the region the area of this slice
between P and Q now you know the first
thing I hope that you'll notice is that
because this shape of the surface can be
in many different ways the particular
cross section that we get does depend on
the choice of x0 different slices
different planes X equal X 0 will give
us different curves of intersection the
point is that once we have the curve of
intersection CX is being treated as the
parameter this particular curve is given
by what equation f is a function of X 0
and y CX 0 is being held CX equals x 0
for every point on this curve and so the
area of the region R is the integral
from A to B f of X 0 Y dy and the
question that very often comes up is how
do you find the derivative of a sub R
with respect to X 0 noticing you see
that a sub R is a function of X 0 along
the Y dropping out between the limits a
and B when we perform the operation of
integration a third place that this type
of situation occurs is in solving
certain differential equations for
example suppose were given a particular
curve and that curve determines a region
R between the lines X equal a and X
equal B suppose all we know about the
curve is its slope at any point we know
that slope at any point is given by
dy/dx is some function of x and y which
we don't necessarily have to go into
right now and let's suppose for the sake
of argument that
we solve this first order differential
equation what we'll find if we're lucky
is that Y is some function of X and an
arbitrary constant remember once you
have one solution to a differential
equation you have an infinite family in
terms of a one parameter solution to a
differential equation equation in other
words in finding the area of the region
R in this case there are many curves
that satisfy this particular
differential equation until we know what
specific points are being referred to
over here the best we know for sure is
what that these endpoints are a and B
that the integral integrand is f of X
comma C and we're integrating that with
respect to X from A to B I fraudulently
put a C in here because I think what I
was trying to emphasize for you is that
when you look at this thing observe that
this integral is a function of C along
namely when you integrate this thing you
integrate with respect to X the X drops
out all you have left here is a see a
sub R then is a function of C and in
many cases what we would like to do is
see how fast the area changes as a
function of C in other words how do we
change the area in as a function of
changing the constant the arbitrary
constant C and I have enough exercises
in the assignment to give you concrete
flow on this all I'm trying to give you
here is an overview of the entire topic
and the reason I want to give you this
overview is that it's hinted at in the
textbook but this topic is not covered
there in fact the reason that I had you
read that particular section of the
textbook before the lecture this time
you notice that usually we start with a
lecture this time I had you read the
textbook first because the way the
textbook covered this topic is
essentially nothing more than the way we
tackled a different problem last
semester and I want you to see that the
problem done in the Thomas text is not a
new problem it's one that we've done
before but that with the tools that we
now have available we could have tackled
a more significant problem and that's
the one I'm electing to do here and what
I want to show you the key steps on
because they're not in the text but I
will leave the reinforcement for the
exercises at any rate hopefully now when
you see
integral of this type it will not bother
you too much in other words don't worry
about how do you integrate a function of
two independent variables when you see
something like this it means that there
is some implicitly implied domain for X
X in other words we have some function
of X I don't know let's say the domain
of that the domain of G might very well
be say all X's between two values say C
and D but who cares about that right now
the important point is that G is defined
on a certain set of values X and what it
says is to compute the output of the G
machine U for the given X you fix that X
and integrate f of X comma Y dy between
a and B notice you see during the
integration X is being treated as a
constant so that to all intents and
purposes this is an ordinary integral
but because X isn't a bonafide constant
meaning what it's a constant only in the
sense that once chosen it remains fixed
for this particular integration
different values of X will give me
different integrals here and
consequently a very natural question
that comes up is how does my function G
which depends on X how does that vary as
X varies in other words the key question
is simply this first of all given G
define this way one does G prime even
exist does DG DX DS exist and two if it
does exist what is it okay in other
words the question that we're raising is
if this if we can find G prime of X how
do we do it in terms of looking at the
right hand side and let me not try to
guess the answer here the answer does
turn out to be in this particular case
one that you might have guessed but I
prefer to show you that we don't have to
guess point one point two if you do
guess you won't always be that lucky
that's my finale for today's lecture but
let me see if I can survive to get to
the finale first let me see how we'll
tackle a problem like this first of all
to see if G prime exists at some value X
0 what we have to do way back to the
very beginning of Part 1 the same old
definition for an ordinary derivative we
have to compute the limit of
X sub 0 plus h minus G of X sub 0 over H
taken in the limit as H approaches 0
notice what the G machine does what the
G machine does is it feeds X into the
integrand here and integrates this with
respect to Y from A to B so if the input
of my G machine is x0 plus h that means
that the X is replaced by x0 plus h here
G of x0 plus h is simply integral from A
to B F of x0 plus h comma Y dy similarly
G of x0 is integral from A to B F of x0
y dy I now want to form this difference
and noticing again this is all calculus
of a single variable that the difference
of two definite integrals is the
definite integral of the difference I
can conclude that G of x0 plus h minus G
of X 0 is simply this single integral
over here now my next step in
determining G prime of x0 is I must
divide this by H notice by the way that
H is an arbitrary increment but once
chosen remains fixed notice that H is a
constant as far as this integration is
concerned consequently to divide by H it
is permissible to bring the H inside the
integrand in other words technically
speaking the H should be here but since
H is a constant with respect to Y the
integral can be have the H brought in
why do I want to bring the H in here let
me again
Telegraph what I'm reading up to
obviously when I'm going to compute G
Prime my next step is to take the limit
of this as H approaches 0 with H in here
I look at this and what I hope is that
by this amount of time at least the
following minimum amount of material has
rubbed off on you in a second nature way
and if I look at this expression in
brackets as X as H approaches 0 this is
precisely the definition of what we mean
by the partial of f of X Y with respect
to X evaluated at x 0yc this is what the
change in F CY is held constant
we're taking this over a change from X 0
to X 0 plus h and dividing by H this is
a partial of F with respect to X that's
why I want to bring the H inside so now
I say ok G prime of X 0 by definition is
this limit I now want to take the limit
of this expression and by the way notice
what I'd love to do now is to jump right
in here and say aha this is just the
partial of F with respect to X evaluated
x0 y0 but the thing I would like you to
notice and again going back to part 1 of
our course one of the big things that we
talked about under the heading of
uniform convergence there is a very
dangerous thing in general to
interchange the order of limit and
integration this says what first perform
the integration and then take the limit
what we would like to be able to do is
first take the limit and then take and
then integrate the result now you know
we did see that provided the integrand
was continuous these operations were
permissible but we'll talk about that a
little later for the time being let's
simply summarize by saying if the limit
operation and the integration operation
can be interchanged then the derivative
which this thing here is what this is my
G of X the derivative of G of X with
respect to X has the very delightful
form that essentially all I have to do
is take the derivative operation come
inside the integrand and replace the
derivative with respect to X by the
partial derivative with respect to X in
other words to the derivative of the
integral from A to B f of X Y dy is the
integral from A to B the partial of F
with respect to X dy provided of course
that the limit and the integration are
interchangeable in particular this will
be true if F and F sub X exist in our
continuous and to straighten out the
range and the domain and what have you
once and for all notice that Y is
allowed to exist between a and B we've
said that X is going to exist on some
domain between C and D notice that
saying that Y is between a and B and X
is between C and D geometrically says
that F
is defined on a rectangle see okay
and then what we're saying is under
these conditions to integrate and
integral with a parameter we with
respect to that parameter all we have to
do is come inside the integral sign and
differentiate take the partial
derivative with respect to what is being
used as the parameter in this case it's
X which is the parameter now the only
danger with this particular thing and by
the way notice not only is there a
danger here that I'm going to mention
the danger is this looks so easy you may
be saying why they do it the hard way
why he just tell us this was the right
way of doing it and the point is it just
happens to be one of those coincidences
where the rigorous way Lee yields a
logical answer which is consistent with
what is probably our intuitive guess but
it's not always going to happen that way
and the example that I have in mind now
goes back to what we were talking about
at the beginning of the lecture namely I
want to give you an application of the
chain rule and here's what that
application comes in I now call this
well I don't know what to call it let's
just call it variable limits of
integration same problem as before it's
gonna cause the chain rule to come in
now
the only difference is going to be and
this is the full warning you don't have
to know that right now I don't have the
same problem as before what I had before
I had that G of X was integral f of X Y
dy
between the two constants a and B now
I'm going to let my constants of
integration also depend on the parameter
C all the constants of integration have
to be our constants as far as Y is
concerned okay what I'm saying is what
makes this problem different from the
previous one is suppose that it happens
that instead of being given a nice
rectangle to play around with I'm given
a couple of curves like this in the XY
plane see this this would be a of X this
would be y equals B of X see what I'm
saying now is that not only does the
integral the integrand depend on what
value of x i pick but the limits of
integration as I'm finding a cross
sectional area of a surface you see the
limits of the integral themselves depend
the choice of X constant as far as Y is
concerned but depend on X you see now
what happens is
that my parameter appears in the limits
as well as just in the integrand and now
you see also what this means is if I try
the previous approach of computing G of
X plus Delta X etc I'm in trouble
because the only way I can combine two
integrals and put them under the same
integral sign is if they're between the
same limits of integration notice here
for example that if I replace X by X
plus Delta X I not only change the
integrand but notice that the limits
become what a of X plus Delta X B of X
plus Delta X and those in general unless
a and B happen to be constants will vary
with X in fact let's look at it this way
this is the problem we should have
started with in the sense that constant
limits of integration are a special case
of this at any rate what I want to show
you is that this particular problem can
be handled very nicely in terms of the
chain rule namely what we do here is we
observe that first of all Y is not
really a variable here it's integrated
out so what we what we think of is let's
think of a of X as being some variable U
let's think of B of X as being some
variable V let's write down the function
of three independent variables U V and X
okay well that function B it'll be the
integral let u V and X be arbitrary
independent variables look at the
integral from u to V f of XY dy this is
obviously dependent upon you it's
dependent upon V and it's dependent upon
X the place that the chain rule comes in
is that in our particular problem U and
V cannot be arbitrary but rather you
must be that particular function a of X
and V must be the particular function V
of X consequently G of X is simply what
it's H of U V X where u is a of X and V
is B of X
consequently to find G prime of X what
we want is H prime of X and to find H
prime as a function of X see the chain
rule here you can be expressed in terms
of X V can be expressed in terms of X
obviously X has already expressed in
terms of X so this is really implicitly
a function of X alone
Soji so by the chain rule what I'd like
to be able to do is to combine these
three pieces of information to find H
prime of X and remember how the chain
rule works I'm not going to beat that to
death we've just had two units on that
let's just say it rather quickly G prime
of X is the partial of H with respect to
U times u prime of X plus the partial of
H with respect to V times V prime of x
times the partial of H with respect to x
times X prime of X which of course is
just 1 in other words writing this thing
out G prime of X is simply this what is
H the partial of H with respect to U
let's come back here for a second and
remember what H is H is this integral I
want to take the partial of that with
respect to u that means I have to
investigate this now here's the
interesting point where as u V and X are
independent variables what does it mean
when you say you're taking the partial
with respect to u it means that you're
treating V and X as constants now if V
and X are being treated as constants
what I have is simply what I'm taking a
derivative with respect to a variable
where the only place the variable
appears appears is as the lower limit of
the integrand notice I claim that that's
nothing more than minus f of X comma u
did I go inside the integrand in other
words i differentiate the integral that
leaves me just the integrand and replace
the variable by the variable of
integration you hear and because it's
the lower limit I put in the minus sign
now while I go through that very fast
that's why I had you read this
assignment first notice that the
assignment in the textbook does not
touch what I'm talking about but rather
seems to review that topic that we
covered under part one that if you want
to take an ordinary derivative with
respect to u integral from u to a G of Y
dy the answer would just be minus G of U
and that's exactly what I did in here I
put an XS constants here it was the only
variable in here was u that will be
emphasized again in the exercise
in a similar way the partial of H with
respect to V means this thing notice now
that U is being treated as a constant X
is being treated as a constant to
differentiate this my variable appears
only as an upper limit on the integrand
that means I come inside the integral
sign replace the integral by just the
function itself replacing what the
variable by the limit of those replacing
Y that's the only in two variables
integration by the upper limit V in
other words this is f of X comma V
alright and finally the partial of H
with respect to X is this integral here
notice now that U and V are being
treated as constants with U and V being
free of this constants that's the
special case that we started our lecture
with namely to differentiate with
respect to a parameter when the
parameter appears only as part of the
integrand so how do we do that we come
inside this is the integral from u to V
the partial of F with respect to X dy
putting the whole thing together
recalling among other things that the u
DX since U is a of X is just a prime of
X and that DV DX is B prime of X what
this says and again I want you to see
the beauty of the chain rule here
because at least to my way of thinking I
don't see anything at all intuitive
about the result I'm going to show you
and that as as soon as you make the
variables the the limits of integration
variable to differentiate and integral
involving a parameter you see again
what's the parameter here X we integrate
with respect to Y this is a constant as
far as Y is concerned see intuitively
you might say gee all you've got to do
is take the derivative sign bring it
inside and this should be the answer to
the same as we did before the point is
and this is where many serious mistakes
are made in problems involving integrals
of this type is that the reason that our
intuitive way happened to be right in
the simpler case was that these were
constants with respect to X now they're
variables well it turns out is if you
just wrote this thing down you would be
wrong
what is the correction factor again come
back to here
the correction factor is this here which
we've just started to compute again just
saying it if you wrote this term down to
get the correct answer
you'd have to tack on what B prime of x
times f of X comma B of X that means
what you think of a Y is being over here
for the particular value of x you
replace Y by B of X though as you look
at f of X comma Y and every place you
see a y replace it by B of X and then
subtract off from that a prime of x
times f of X comma a of X now again I
suspect that for many of you it's the
first time that you've seen something
like this because I say it's a topic
which I believe was a natural one to
occur in the textbook but for some
reason it doesn't appear there because
of the importance of the concept the
number of times it appears in physical
applications the number of times that
one has to differentiate with respect to
an integral I don't know the physical
applications well enough I to lecture on
them but it does occur in probability
theory among other places it appears in
any subject involving integral equations
and the like that I wanted to give you
the experience of seeing what the
concept means to have you hear me say it
and then I will spend the exercises
trying to drive home the computational
know-how so that you will be able to do
these things at least in a mechanical
way independently of whether the theory
made that much sense because of the lack
of physical example motivation other
than what I did at the beginning
at any rate keep in mind though that in
terms of our present topic where we're
talking about the chain rule this is a
certainly noble application to show an
important place in the physical world
where knowledge of the chain rule plays
a very important role and with that I
might just as well conclude today's
lecture and until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate